Oh, my gosh, Hi, Josh, how are you?
Great, lovely to see you again, definitely.
Oh, it's really, really lovely to see you.
Your family has been on the front lines of the pandemic
since it began.
And I'm just so in awe of your entire family
what has their journey been like?
What has it been like for you?
Yeah, first of all, I agree.
And a huge thank you to Leah and Michael.
I so respect what those people are doing
partly because I've seen what my family,
my sister is a COVID what she's called a PA
a physician's assistant.
And she went and worked in a hospital
in the very center of the beginning of the pandemic
in New York City
when things were pretty rough to say the least.
And then my father is a emergency room physician
who now is doing COVID testing.
He's doing COVID vaccinations.
And my mother also as well, she's a lot like those guys
in your earlier section where she's on the side of the road
with cars, pulling up on an island.
It was cool, I spoke to my sister the other day
and I said, "How are you doing?"
And she said, "For so long this thing has been so hard
and just physically, emotionally hard."
She said, "But the last couple of weeks
I started to feel this big transition."
Because she said things started to calm down in her work
and she felt the shift and she felt the hope
that people are feeling because of the vaccination.
And my family is adamant, all of them
that the vaccination is a way out,
just a place in an idea, even in your head
that gives you some sense of freedom.
And my father and mother both now
can see their grandchildren
because they've been vaccinated.
So, it's been a really beautiful thing to watch
the work that they're doing.
That is what I'm so glad that you gifted us with
because I want optimism that is grounded in reality.
And so hearing that, that they're on the front lines,
they're the ones who are doing the work,
and they feel the shift and we can benefit from that wisdom
and have that realistic hope.
Thank you, it's invaluable for you to share that with us.
Thank you.
Okay, absolutely.
I know that something film in your family home
when you were younger
and it had a light bulb go off, will you tell me about that?
My story is kind of beautiful.
We were living on a small island in South Carolina
and I'd never been around movies.
I'd honestly never even seen a play
at that point in my life.
And this little island, for some reason
this little Canadian film company got snowed out
of where they were filming some scenes on a beach
and they needed a place that didn't have terrible weather
in the middle of winter.
And they came down and they rented the house
that we were living in as a production office.
And they filmed some scenes literally in front of the house
and the sand dunes.
And I was, I think, an eight, nine year old boy
and I snuck out and I literally covered myself in the weeds,
the weeds that are in the sand.
And I watched the scene like laying on the beach.
I watched the scene between two teenage lovers
and I remember just being, so, I mean, my heart was racing.
I was scared of being caught
and it was magical at a level
that I don't know if I've ever even felt anything,
making movies as much as I've sort of yearned
for that first high, I guess.
But I decided in that moment to be an actor.
I love that story.
It's great to find a sense of purpose in all of our lives.
And I do think that people are finding a sense of purpose
in ways that they did not know possible.
And I see the evidence of it everywhere.
And literally the show is here to talk about that.
Well, that's what I'm gonna say.
You must be feeling that, doing the show, right?
Literally the show wants to be a platform
to seek and find these stories out.
I love it all.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪